what's the deal with everything peanuts
have you ever dated a black woman
uh hooked up with one in college oh yeah
was that in the book no yeah they made
me take it out
um
bran Tom brand nah she was she was she
was really beautiful yeah yeah it was
just one time yeah we like would flirt a
lot
um through like a couple years of
college and then it was a senior week we
went to this a dude she uh
we're staying at this place in Myrtle
Beach it's like about like 25 of us
seniors yeah and I walk by the pool and
she shoves me in when when they right
like she's that's her playing and I was
like yeah so in my mind I'm like I'm
gonna get her back yeah well I go to
shover and she grabs me
as I'm as I'm shoving her so I go in
with her and she can't swim oh and she
is full like full panic but her Panic is
so like I mean picture a 10. yeah that
she's like drowning me oh [ __ ] yes like
so I had to actually shove her
off right and looked like I was trying
to kill her yeah and then like
get air yeah and then and she was like
frantically and I was like she was like
why'd you do that I'm like what do you
mean why'd I do that you shoved me in
the pool I shove you in the pool like
wow yeah so did and that led to sex yeah
she was like she was like really wanting
to hook up yeah and um
and then they were like uh telling me
that she's in the my room I was like
what really
um she was in the shower in the shower
in your room
she wasn't afraid of drowning
apparently wearing uh shorts short
pajama sleepers it's bad with Crocs with
no shoes look at those her Crocs with no
socks got some games over here some ham
rocks baby this is a Penn Station outfit
right here
all he needs is a pair of alligator
shoes to go with it
down in the bag
now here's I got no spots tonight and
I'm going back to clean my apartment so
I wanted to stay in the so you showed up
to work like a homeless guy plus I have
no clothes you're dressed for a call for
help
oh man I do look like a jumper don't I I
think at 10 o'clock jumper on the GW
Bridge I heard you're on the weight the
loss game now all right trying I heard
you're trying I don't know I am trying
mark thank you very much no he's not
check out that patreon.com for updates
oh sorry I didn't mean to bring it I
went I went dropped about 30 and then I
went up about 20. so I'm trying to go
back down again you're low 10. that was
yesterday
damn you talk about weight like a casino
I'm up I'm up right now
they switched dealers I got screwed
Pit Boss give me the eye
it's a Barbecue Pit Boss
I followed your lead I cut I'm I cut
porn I'm done no more porn no why swear
to God why I'm getting sober on porn
why because I just don't I don't think
it's good it's not and I find myself
going to it sometimes I'm like I'm not
even gonna jerk off why am I looking at
this [ __ ] yeah sometimes I'll look at it
without intent to jerk off like I just
want to see what's on there so I'm gonna
I'm cutting it out when it was when's
the first time four days clean four days
I'm clean really well why don't should I
you know do a pack I would love to do it
together all right so I did it last
night okay so day one no do it tonight
what do you mean start again yes so
should I watch it right now and then
start again tonight you know because
I'll watch it tonight again and start at
zero let's do that so because I was
planning on watching it tonight I want
to jerk off tonight so I would like to
start off all right all right so let's
start from zero tonight great so tonight
at midnight the last last time last time
last time 11 59 yeah if you watch it at
midnight you've broken it right okay
could I ask you this too what are the
rules no porn
he lives like seven blocks for me it's
so weird that's a that's a wild thing
isn't that weird and he's always left
seven blocks I used to do a bit about
how first time I met him he's petting a
cat and I and I went up to him and uh I
was like what's up with the categories I
rescued her from the side of the road
and I nursed her back to health and I
was like so you did have it in you oh
yeah yeah no he lives seven blocks away
he's
very close it's very but the cat was
cute as hell I'll give the cat there
it's a good cat he's like named him Sam
back to the bucket we go
all right everybody make some noise for
Gary Falcon everyone Gary Falcon here we
go
oh here he comes over here it's Gary
falcon
it's over here
[Music]
[Applause]
Gary Falcon everybody put your hands
together for Gary falcon
foreign
[Applause]
what's going on
it's good to be here on the Real
Housewives of Kiev
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway
I just got back from the doctor
what is AIDS
laughs
[Applause]
yeah
you know what kind of a man you are
how soon you pull your dick out when you
walk up to a urinal
for me it's a block away
[Applause]
thank you for having me
foreign
wow
oh my goodness
this is our first time ever having Gary
Falcon on the show before you might be
one of the best Brands spanking new
comedians we've ever seen
well thank you so much Tony for having
me
you would get gay bash on a Coldplay
concert
watch out
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah you got me good there Gary
[Laughter]
my goodness guys have you ever seen
anybody quite as it make a debut quite
as strong as Gary Fountain incredible
amazing
wow I've never seen a a missing children
posted that could talk
[Music]
whoa
Tony
I mean Tony watch out this teddy bear's
got teeth
God bless now
I didn't know Cody had a brother
I didn't know Santa had AIDS
holy [ __ ] I'm editing my special right
now and boy oh boy is it annoying why I
said I'm particular you know like I just
like I don't put a lot of stuff out
online
and I've been told a million times I
should and I just don't do it and now
that I haven't done it I feel like I'm
just gonna wait till the special comes
out and that'll be my version of that
yeah are you are you hesitant to put
stuff out I say the n-word a lot and
that's really what it is oh yeah that'll
do it where did you get the confidence
to think that all these guys wanted to
[ __ ] you
we're sorry dude I know right now you
you're [ __ ] I know you're the guy now
I know that because
you wear an extra thick corduroy [ __ ]
I'm not asking anybody anything anymore
you're not going does this look good I
get it
like should there be a space between my
socks and my pants
ah I get it brother I understand you
know what I mean you're not asking
anybody anything anymore but believe it
or not I just get dressed High though
this looks good right yeah you put on
weird [ __ ] now like it doesn't matter oh
yeah you're [ __ ] nuts right now
you're going crazy but when I but that
corner is okay but extra thick
dude I remember one time Colin quick
came out of his house with brown
corduroy Converse I go you got to take
those off go take them off he took them
off I threw them on The Wire
I gotta go get new shoes I'm like you
know when I'm not I won't allow oh [ __ ]
I love you you're one of my Idols yeah
get those off yeah yeah we came back
they were gone somebody [ __ ] climbed
up
Gabe Davis he's a wide receiver for the
Buffalo Bills absolute Legend yeah uh he
brought a couple of players to the show
so the Bros are there this is like
Friday night Saturday Friday night the
Bros are there that's sick uh which was
very scary to see the Bros yeah you
don't realize how big NFL players are
until they're in the Buffalo helium
Green Room which is a closet
yeah
hey fellas me and Lamar were pressed up
against each other in the corner while
like 10 NFL dudes surrounded us it was
awesome Jesus hot guys too oh yeah so
then they they hook us up with three
tickets to the game we got there at
kickoff but get in Gabe Davis honors me
with an incredible performance yeah true
no he did he honored me he really did
and he really grew with his boy who Bert
was [ __ ] up we were drinking he was
like Gabe's doing this for you right now
it's insane so after the game Gabe comes
over to the where we're sitting yeah
takes his [ __ ] Jersey off signs it
and gives it to me it's me and little
kids
I'm I'm drunk in a Bill's hoodie with
glasses and a hat
for real everybody there thought I was a
[ __ ] guy and the NFL films was like
filming
exciting it giving it to me I was like
yeah it was like a crowd of children
and I was standing there I'm like how
old are you boys
before you said about his friend like
he's doing this for you I was thinking
like he probably truly was charged up oh
he was he went to the show he 100. he
went to the show and he was like I'm
about to [ __ ] I'm gonna honor him he
definitely was running faster than usual
I bet he was fast as hell all right dude
I'm telling you and it's so funny to be
like announcers but man he's really
putting it on
the crowd
good you might be his Muse dude I could
be Gabe Davis's Muse
so it gives me the Jersey we're hanging
out then we we go dude this is where the
this is where this whole thing gets
incredibly funny is just lemare
lemare around NFL players he was
treating him like he was like a child
yeah he dude he's like 32. yeah with
like he's 10 years older than these
players he's 10 years older
they gave him a 3X it was down to his
knees dude he had his hands in his
sleeves the whole time he's like he's
[ __ ] up yeah yeah it's for real
autistic without a doubt it was he was
saying they're rightful dude outrageous
they're Right Guard
that place with bills is a monster
here's the black dude in the chains yeah
yeah in like a cool shirt lemare stands
in front he's talking to one of the one
of us yeah one of the family you're
talking to him maybe his family yeah the
mayor stands next to them he's mid
conversation it just goes
I've never seen dude I've never seen his
hands still in the hoodie
I've never seen someone hold a pound
longer an announced an unanswered pound
dude he just
finally finally this dude not looking at
him goes
it keeps talking and then there goes
it was incredible God damn it so then
we're hanging out after
dude he kept doing this the rest of the
night he was just drilling people the
Bill's got an onslaught of autism from
sassenal America it was incredible I've
never seen anything like it oh my
goodness dude we're hanging out after
Gabe takes us through the facilities
while we're walking through the
facilities the mayor's walking just
lemarin Gabe Davis are walking and
lemares like how does it feel to reach
your dreams of being an NFL player it
was like what the [ __ ] who is this
oh [ __ ] and then we're in the locker
room and me and Lambert got a picture
back to back oh God damn it dude well
the whole Bills team watches
no this is the beginning this is nothing
this is nothing compared to what's it
about to happen oh my God so we go to we
go to Josh Allen and or we go to the
teams like dinner yeah and just in a
restaurant it was great it was wonderful
lemare is sitting it's a long table it's
lemare in this one white out I forget
who it was sitting next sitting a chair
apart but no one else is around them
we're across the table I hear Lemire
look over at him and go other than us
being black what do you think you and I
have in common
it was just like and the dude was real
like yo who is this
whose man is this he wasn't having it at
all
and the mayor was like what it's a good
question no shame
the guy's like sitting with his family
oh my God so we're laughing about that
we're laughing about it the mayor again
doesn't take the hint that maybe he
should stop doing this oh my God five
minutes later I don't know again this
guy's not talking he's just asking
questions like he's sitting eating and
then being like
he goes what what do you search on
YouTube
this is NFL wide receiver he's like I
don't know man like what he's like he's
just like what are you talking about you
know what I love about Italians Italians
a real can be really tough right but
they get real sensitive about produce oh
produce is very yeah they go look I
[ __ ] break your neck but take a look
at these tomatoes
people you know people start looking to
be like looking at me funny yeah it's
like pick a cantaloupe you don't tell me
how to fix my hand alone you almost
could see Italians in a supermarket
where people pick their produce quick
you can almost see Italians going it's a
[ __ ] shame yeah disgusting it's a
shame take your time I judge if you
don't if you don't do a lot if you're
not if you're not grabbing three to five
tomatoes you don't know what you do yeah
if you're doing a first pull if you're
grabbing a first tomato
very good again good get rid of this
[ __ ] if you're not giving a squeeze oh
and if you're going from the top please
you got me started because you're great
for the top the new one's coming up the
right ones
it's particularly well done when people
uh do it in print because in print you
know they'll take things people have
said and they'll write this and they're
like someone said this and you're like
wow is that the full context of how that
was said because if it was comedy it's
not going to be really ready I'll give
you an example one of the first
interviews I did with the newspaper
um I I thought SNL was going to be like
a feather in my cap when I was running
and it turned out the people in
Minnesota didn't really see the
connection between comedy and the United
States yeah
and so
um and it was if anything used against
me so one of the first interviews I did
I'm asked the first question was uh when
you are at SNL did you ever do cocaine
yeah I went uh
yes uh but I only did a little
and only so I could stay awake late
enough to make sure the Belushi didn't
do too much
okay yeah now
you got that that was a joke yeah yeah
the [ __ ] reporter writes it up Alvin
I can acknowledge doing cocaine while he
was a a a
writer SNL uh but said he only did a
little
so he could stay awake late enough to
make sure that cast member John Belushi
didn't do too much Belushi later died of
a drug overdose yeah yeah
and that's every [ __ ] thing I'd ever
done I'm sorry you use the language I
know that offends you guys so
there's some girls that maybe are out of
your league and you're like they
wouldn't give you the the chance because
you don't have enough followers yeah
and I'd be like if I could just get
stuck in an elevator with this girl for
45 minutes I'm in just to give your
personality just she has she has to I'll
I'll do push all the buttons she'll be
like oh my God this guy's oh this guy's
such a goof yeah
what's your opening line it so it just
stuck it's it's like not working well it
depends none of the buttons you want to
role play with me yeah I'm the hot girl
oh uh you mean do you want to be the hot
girl always I am a hot girl but well in
this situation it's me approaching hot
girl I'm Rick no no you're the hot girl
thank you
we're in
um okay I'm on my phone I'll walk in and
then and then so we're on an elevator
and then um then when we're going while
we're going uh down it'll it'll uh it'll
you know shake a little and they'll be
like what the [ __ ] you know like you'll
be a little scared okay what was that
I gotta walk in first okay I was just
being a hot girl in general okay
[Music]
iPhone
[Music]
oh yeah yeah me too nice
oh I guess got a text from
my son
he said I'm the best daddy in the world
it's very wholesome what's your son's
name
honestly it's I feel like I've known him
for so long it's too late to ask and I
don't remember and I don't know what to
do I'm not
I just call him little buddy
he's yours not necessarily I just trying
to flirt with you and I don't have a son
I just thought it'd be funny though have
you think of me as Daddy whoa what just
happened
um what is this did you plan this
that was my heart
okay I that's very
excuse me
I farted
omelette
yes what's your name I used to [ __ ] on
Americans so [ __ ] hard when it came
to drinking just because because we
sucked at it well that was certainly my
perception because you get Americans
being like you know because you guys
don't get to drink until 21. uh well
yeah yeah but like I remember being like
18 coming over here and meeting 19 year
olds would be like we're underage
drinking I'm like that's not 13 is
underage drinking yeah I come from yeah
like you do that too yeah yeah I I yeah
I guess it does I know it happens but it
feels just so much more [ __ ] you know
strict here and but it feels more punk
rock too or like I imagine drinking
during prohibition here that type of
drinking must have been fun yeah yeah
cause you're breaking the rules you're
not supposed to be doing it like vodka
goes like down somebody's [ __ ] drain
in a [ __ ] bottle because there's
under seven houses and pops up through a
chimney in the back and like the cops
outside no it's time for chimney podcast
NASCAR came from was Bootleggers trying
to escape the cops really that's the
origin of NASCAR give it a goog and they
were only escaping in one Circle yeah
they didn't know they were hammered
tattoos no I can't be committed to an
idea like that that's the way I feel I
just you've did your kids no no see you
would think but I actually have Catholic
scripture on my arm what is uh scripture
I have scripture and Crosses like I'm
fighting in the Crusades I just went to
Ireland we talked about it last episode
where they told me I was in Belfast they
told me I can't if what these Catholic
tattoos do not go to the Protestant bars
with with those tattoos you'll get in
big trouble for that interesting I swear
to God the tour guide was like listen
most likely no you have an American
accent so you should be okay but you
don't want to get some guy who fought in
the wars who's you know had too many
this is what I told them when I was on
the stage because they're not Wars stop
stop with this horse [ __ ] this is why
the Jews and the Arabs control
everything and they should you're fine
and I said this to them on the stage and
they clapped and applauded I said you
look the same all you do you're
screaming at each other over like this
little small translation in the Bible
shut up these aren't Wars six people die
you blow up a [ __ ] baby carriage no
one cares okay these are on [ __ ] Wars
shut up get drunk be happy you [ __ ]
leprechauns stop acting like this is a
big deal we're all supposed to give a
[ __ ] about nobody [ __ ] cares so and
that's what I said I'm like they're all
like screaming and they were heckling
about Catholics and Protestants like
nobody gives a [ __ ]
it's over Dubai they're building
buildings that are to [ __ ] going up
to the sun yeah you people have stoned
things from [ __ ] 1600. yeah you guys
headed out yeah you barely have toilets
yeah the best thing you've ever come up
with is a [ __ ] scone that's right
which is pretty good British though oh
is it everything we got is British the
best thing Irish people have come up
with is whiskey and [ __ ] right lying
making stuff up Blarney and whiskey yeah
because you need those you need that
whiskey and [ __ ] that should be the
name of this episode I like that happy
Halloween well I won't have the ad wrap
if it's the name my brother was four
years older than me and he had his crew
like if I was 10 he was 14 big
difference between tennis you're right
about that so my brother that was like
you know a few 14 year olds and there
was only like two or three ten-year-olds
and um and then there was like some 18
year olds they really didn't hang out
with us that much and then the 22 year
olds you know who lived in the back in
the back shed right you know what I mean
they got divorced too so there was a
bunch of levels I was part of the
younger everybody getting divorced and
then it ends up we end up just like
playing football on the streets and
we're just monitoring whose mom uh is
dating whose mom has a new boyfriend oh
and what kind of car yeah
look at your mom's boyfriend's car look
at your mom's boyfriend then you just
talk [ __ ]
my best friend [ __ ]
yeah what's the last time you saw Fiero
did it in my best friend's mom dated
this [ __ ] you know cause every now and
then my mom was kind of hot so she she
even dated like a dude from the
California Angels back when they were
Juan Benitez my mom dated that really
yeah my mom was a little hottie so when
she when she when um my stepdad finally
left him and left her alone with three
kids to raise that was my stepdad but
that was my older brother like we'll
come back to that I got yeah because I
want to I want you to explain it it's
complicated all right my like my mom and
dad stepdad a lot of weird [ __ ] but um
not weird typical actually but
my my friend's mom dad she scored she
got a boyfriend that drove like a big
ass truck driver and he was all a
Mexican guy but like Americanized kinda
uh born in Mexico but been out out here
for like 15 years got a good job truck
driver and he was all about Peterbilt
like it's just you know he was just like
Peterbilt belt buckles so he had like a
decent car like he had a Camaro or some
[ __ ] like oh [ __ ]
Matt's mom's coming up and we're like oh
[ __ ] and he was like so proud
that his mom got uh a boyfriend with a
job
that's early for him too yeah
cause he never had a dad just like me my
dad was always gone too everybody's dad
was gone so his dad was gone everybody
dealt with it in different ways but he
loved his
mom's new boyfriend so much he's
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah and then he left there
and now time for some October podcasting
stats to wrap up this video for you guys
Robert Kelly appeared on the most shows
as a guest this month going on six
different podcasts in October including
The Joe Rogan Experience flagrant Bert
cast long days with the honest Papa's
Chrissy chaos and are you garbage the
second most appearances came from Greg
Fitzsimmons with three different shows
and Duncan Trussell went on two
different shows being two bears one cave
and kill Tony the most viewed episode
from October was flagrant's roast of
Kanye West with 1.2 million views and
please let me know any podcasts or shows
I missed in this video that you think
deserves to be in the best in November
coming out next month thank you so much
for watching this video and remember if
you'd like to join the fastest growing
community of like-minded Comedy fans on
the internet and in the world
be sure to subscribe to joke world right
now this is a channel covering all
things comedy literally anything you
could think of in the comedy universe or
in the world it'll be on this page thank
you again for watching and we'll see you
Monday with the comedy news
[Music]
thank you